the question that I would like to have
you leave here with
is you know a new appreciation of how
hard it is to figure out what is going
and what is going on it's very easy to
smooth it all out and say you know that
the Pentagon runs it all and so forth on
but once you start beating
I mean the world is a labyrinth a sponge
of interconnected lathering
interst sees the weirdest connections
you know who knew
and what they were doing about
and then you know these reports that
come in
and some are false at sub-material
mountain to old eleven all
paint a picture of the excruciating
weirdness
and people are just not pushing the
right button
I mean I guarantee you you take five
dried gram
so psilocybin in silent Darwinists in
your own living room on a Saturday night
you know ferdinand magellan move over
you you will see things
has ever seen before
and these things are real they have
existential validity they
hearts Android
bring them back
and fire
we are surrounded
aliens of alien
[Music]
I am irrational
if you press
these weird stone
you can overcome
the trailer
nobody ever gets kid
by a flying saucer except
with your BA in Psychology and your
friendship with Romain you can be
kidnapped by flying
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is going
flower it
the last
where it is
what they were doing
be warned
Ranieri
[Music]
people are just not pushing the right
I guarantee you
take five dried grams
[Music]
don't bring them with you
one has ever seen before
and these things are real they have a
stand
[Music]
we are surrounded
I am
these weird stone
your own which is you know that
by a flying saucer except
you can
with your PA of psychology your
friendship with Romain
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]